tu connais les questions qu'on des
questions comme comment vous allez
commencer
oui bon ça c'est très content moi ça a
juste un peu moins cons
par exemple vu est ce que tu préfères
passé une nuit avec un mec que tu aime à
la folie
ou une semaine avec un mec que tu aimes
moyennement ça c'est vraiment une
question super coureur testé même une
demie n'y ait même que j'aime évidemment
alors et si tu étais obligé par jour que
tu ais faite prisonnière
on se dit ouais c'est une idée comme ça
c'est un jeu et ce à la baisse et les
questions alors j'ai fait prisonnier
puis on te dit voilà on est obligé de
faire l'amour avec la personne avec qui
on va être enfermé dans ce type de
cellule je vois la situation est ce que
tu préfères faire l'amour avec une fille
ou avec les qui vous pousse à
l'homosexualité alors je sais pas moi
y'a des gens qu'elle est allée à wez non
c'est pas trop mauvais sens tu vois ça
l'a fait je n'ai jamais essayé les films
et je crois que si j'étais obligé je
préfère encore définitifs elles
définitif au genre sauvegarder la saga
j'ai pas encore sécurisée alors
maintenant question impossible à mon
sens mais certaines personnes peuvent y
répondre
est ce que tu préfères renault ou
goldman ne sais pas célia long silence
la voiture arrive pas j'arrive pas à ma
vie j'en étais sûr à mon avis c'est une
question à laquelle peuvent jantes en 20
ans n'a pas amoindri global à dire
qu'ils sont vraiment choquant pour qui
tu as le plus de circonstances
atténuantes à qui tu trouve le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux mecs qui se tape des petites
filles ça prend ça pour l'argent ou
alors un jeune mec qui toujours pour
l'argent table sur des vieilles on va en
panique il faut qu'on aurait alors
tu as bien compris la question oui oui
maintenant j'essaie d'imaginer le
tableau est bien jeune homme le plus
noir je te demande pas tout faire oui je
pardonne aux jeunes je pardonne aux
jeunes qui tapent sur des vieilles
profession sans cesse ici l'objet de sa
sortie un bon élève à bord d'accord
alors que l'autre il est pas obligé de
payer des petites filles non elle aussi
un pervers
si tu rentres chez toi soir avec un
garde 110 la préfecture ans avec lui un
certain ton fiancé habituel et c'est ça
garçon a rencontré genre la première
question coup de foudre
et puis tu as oublié quelque chose sur
la table de nuit
un objet assez compromettants sur ma
table de oui oui
avant cela il mentir ah oui tu te ramène
chez toi fan ya chez toi olivier quoi
été oublié qu'est ce qui vous gêne le
plus d'avoir oublié mein kampf ou un
godemiché assez terrible hier ya sur la
table et y est tu vas répondre la pièce
qui viennent le bus vis-à-vis du avec ce
mec tu as envie de te montrer vis-à-vis
de lui si tu veux tu peux montrer que si
bien et tout qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui te
gêne le plus désigne moi je crois que
c'est michael ouais quand même pas mal
de bons deuxièmement site était amputé
d'un membre 70 voilà vous avez bien
quelques rues comme c'est pratique on va
être obligé de vous amputé d'un membre
on est obligé toi ça je alors lequel un
bras ou une jambe un bras dans lequel le
bras grotte où le bras vos chiffres
gauche évidemment je suis droitière et
site était maître du monde
tu ferais quoi demain matin entre
éveillant puis devient maître d'une
femme est très vivement stabilité normes
deux maîtres du monde et la première
chose que tu fais se ferait aider les
gens je sais pas comment s'y était
maître du monde peut faire plein de
trucs mais ted qui en première j'ai dû
tout l'argent facile à trouver mais
politique déjà dans tous les pays
wen dans tous les pays déjà il ya du
boulot et beaucoup de boulot et puis
ensuite je taxe je m'appelle je teste
toutes les denrées alimentaires stockées
en surgelé ben ouais monde entier j'en
vois dans les pays sous alimentés
parce qu'il ya des aliments stockées en
surgelé consorts face simplement parce
que vos pâtisseries baisse pour
l'alimentation est spécialisée en deux
mois alors qu'on envoie des cartons de
protéines c'est en france si cubaine
alors donc les maîtres du monde qui peut
tout changer
ou est-ce que tu mettrais la france sur
la carte du monde tu pouvais choisir
tout d'abord je la mets la clique suis
la maîtresse a c'est une île de l'océan
pacifique est en soi une grande
polynésie voir grand portail et any way
et paris tu mettrais ou par rapport à ça
dans paris bien situé
ça va je mettrai pas car il a un minot
noms cités par les destine derrière
question con je te dis la bombe arrive
dans sa mine x l'as monaco nice ouais
elle va tomber sur paris pile sur la
concorde
qu'est ce que tu fais dans les cinq
dernières minutes
je vais te dire je sais pas écouté mon
fiancé a précisé je jette dans ses bras
elles disent tout seul si cela nous on a
du pôle aimerait quand même mais je
crois qu'un maquillage et les façons je
crois que c'est dans un moment par
ailleurs on a besoin de se sentir va
sentir seule école contre lui datant de
satan points c'est pas une prière par
hasard
sinon pour l'au delà ouais par jean
péter sodann au ciel je sais pas du tout
où est ce qu'on va